here to cleanse your palate with some
what to watch let's begin in california
investigating the petrochemical and
fossil fuel industries for their alleged
role in the plastic pollution crisis
california's attorney general rob banta
subpoenaed exxonmobil yesterday bonta
says the industry has deceived the
public for decades about oil-based
plastics products and their damage to
the environment he said the vast
majority of plastic cannot be recycled
and the recycling rate has never been
any higher than nine percent it's put
into a landfill
number one
number two it's burned uh or number
three it ends up other places in our
environment including
our waterways and our oceans
so i don't
bond to accuse exxon mobil of being a
major source of global plastics
pollution exxon mobil says the
allegations are meritless uh the point
that he makes about these plastics um
that don't fully degrade it instead
break up into little tiny pieces these
micro plastics that end up in the
waterways and fish ingest them i mean
the problem is that people find plastic
to be very cheap which it is uh very
useful which it is and there's not a
great replacement so like all the
environmental complaints are true but
the reason people still go with plastic
bags in a lot of places because it's
easy and convenient i mean listen i've
used a paper straw now don't use plastic
with the paper straw just fell apart
right but i'm not using plastic no yeah
pointing it out there are little
individual things we can take like this
is kind of a silly thing but you know uh
face scrubs facial scrubs i learned this
recently facial scrubs generally have
microplastics in them so when you when
you wash your face with them they look
all youthful yeah and they go into the
drain where do they end up in a fish's
stomach so don't use those that's an
example of doing some things if we want
to look youthful what do we do here
look at cucumbers
mark this footage this is the beginning
of the end of vlad's youthful look
i'll look my age tomorrow on monday